hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play black snow ok
this is a game that was requested a lot
actually came out just recently I think
on the 22nd of November it was released
if I recall correctly if you want to
play yourself linked in the description
as always I always like to promote these
games and yes this is a half-life to
modification um I don't know a lot about
it like mostly I try to avoid learning
about the game before I get into it
there seems to be too
Olo well is that oh okay what the hell
is that whoa ah alright then
there seems to be something wrong with
the CCTV ok it seems to just be looping
out and oh haha oops ok I this should be
an interesting experience
haha I'm excited I'm excited cuz I
always love these modifications of games
like this I always feel like there's a
lot to be had from the modding community
and I'm really excited to try something
out now I mean people give it a lot of
flack or people I think people judge
these mods harshly and they seem to
forget that are made by a team totally
free this game is totally free and it's
really well done but what I've seen
hello
fifteen minutes over over yeah we'll be
careful if you want to be control right
now decent voice acting making sentence
you know what they said
static malfunction of arms right last
time I checked gas masks we'll need for
a comms failure mmm yeah I guess
okay oh wait legs guys
I can't moving body can move any signs
of the personnel I um I think you see
something for there I'm sure it's good I
don't even know what we're looking at
that there
this is [ __ ] weeping they doing
hey what's the worst that can happen
shut the [ __ ] up P this reminds me of
the thing oh this looks that that was ah
everything looks awesome like seriously
that looked amazing I'm really really
I'm really excited to get into this
because I always love these excellent
well-made mods and very happy to give it
a try so yeah like I was saying this
reminds me of the thing you know Arctic
station some mysterious entity a team
dispatched to check it out you know I
mean this is called black snow so I'm
assuming it's something on its own huh
oh hello here we go ah okay W to get up
I'm getting up
whoo ow ow oh my balls okay so anyway
I'm parently stuck in a research station
of some sort is obviously half-life 2 so
the visuals are going to be like that
but it's half-life 2 episode 2 so it's
on the latest episode of latest version
of the steam or Source engine by the way
guys valve is working on Source engine -
I found that out very recently so
hopefully we'll be able to look forward
to that ok let's just get this out the
way didn't see anything in there don't
exactly know we're running away from I
never actually got a good look power
level low let's see who there there are
tons of little itty-bitty details in
this and oh that ha ha
there's tons of little details the door
handle seems to have fallen out oh do I
need to pick it back up
yeah ok can't pick that up Wow I mean
seriously I I'm a huge fan of half-life
and man that's just a ton of wow they
grown Whedon here ok so what am I
looking for exactly I hear something
through the windows I have no flashlight
by the looks of it is there nothing over
here
uh-uh-uh-uh-uh ok so anyway besides me
getting lost on the first level the very
first level what is that what the hell
is that there's something up there that
I need hmm okay so besides the door I
can't push the door open really am i
that big of a wuss okay so besides me
being a giant wuss what is that oh hello
thermite oh I need to find me some
thermite everyone knows what thermite is
if you don't know what thermite is just
YouTube thermite you'll see some of the
coolest fire you've ever seen in your
life okay so apparently I need to give
me some thermite to get out of this door
it seems like it would be excessive how
do I get others how do i huh
duh how do I escape you okay don't know
what button I pressed but I did okay so
I need to find me some thermite
seems-seems overkill but you know I've
never been one to go easy whenever I
need to get out of a door hey it's that
logo that's the logo that was flashing
by in the beginning uh anyway let's find
me some chemicals here ah a sheet of
waxed paper I have an inventory I'm
pressing tab
give me my inventory not sure exactly
what I'm looking for
nothing seems like whoa what's up what
did I just press oh hello hey now there
we go all red tip matches that is
phosphorus is an ingredient in thermite
ergo I'm on the right track here so I
just need to look in these cabinets for
more what is that sound I want to know I
would really like to know okay so I just
need to find something else I have red
okay I have the matches where is the
where are the other compounds citric
acid potassium sorbate are these what I
need who's the ingredients hang on let
me look again see you need iron and
oxygen plus aluminum goes to iron and
aluminum aluminum diadem trioxide
okay all right get out of there what a
button is i press to get out of there
yeah uh-huh
control I think it was space I have no
idea okay so I need to make thermite but
I don't know how
okay this mineral solution hydroponics
ah come on I can't get lost but in the
beginning I can't even get out of the
first door this is this is this what my
life has become
I'm such an away what is that I see a
little something I see you I see you go
on there I see you be shiny come on I'm
such an idiot I was such an idiot and
the biggest city in the world
hi I'm the biggest city in the world
cannot figure out beginning of game huh
got it thermite [ __ ] finally got it okay
I put the thermite on the Dori door use
the wax paper put the thermite and light
it with the matches huh Wow how do you
like me now
get open get crack you open how do I
open you oh I put you up it okay with my
face hole ah this looks much better and
much more like a place that I can escape
from what are you
whoa I shocked myself ow owie oh oh okay
so this looks much nicer that only took
me five minutes
haha not a llama I like that I'm a loop
contamination protocol look down in
effect alright buddy
whatever you say okay I'm in the
research lab need to get out of here
what's the dead down there anything no
everything so shiny so I think
everything's something it is not
responding apparently you gotta use a
lot of stuff in here
see okay energy drinks some CCTVs lists
nothing usable there the thermite has
blown through that video games haha why
waste good technology on science and
medicine I agree
Oh like shock myself again I'm such an
a-hole
about a thousand self-inflicted wounds
later don't know what else I could I've
spammed the use button on everything
what do I need to do I need to oh come
on oh you gotta be kidding me that was
right in front of my eyeballs Oh what
did that do did that turn off the power
bollocks no didn't oh did it turn on the
power
ah it turned on the power the car went
on I'm a luke load we go got lit up but
let let that bad Glenna jack daddy XE
okay
Miley face Who am I uh
how may I assist you today who are you I
am Jack the station's integrated
artificial intelligence always good on a
look station also I'd be RG 0.3 ah
around research station on the apex of
the Greenland ice sheets okay whatever
you say bro that he is funded by the
Institute of proto science research and
CHM polar services uh-huh
it can't unlocking or doors thank you up
down over I'm so nice sorry do to the
facility operating under 30 percent
efficient uh-huh power has been diverted
to vital life-support thank you I do not
have sufficient computing power to
respond to your query that is perfectly
okay buddy you're doing a great job
goodbye thank you man an AI that
actually cooperates and helps thank you
so much admittedly I wasted it a bit
more time than I should have
that's okay and I'm a bit more dead than
I should be but that's okay - I'm okay
anyway this is in Greenland instead of
um
Antarctica so it's not quite related to
hello do I need more thermite for that
it's not quite related to what any the
heat helps me recover my strength for
really ha ha hoo Thank You magic healing
heater vent if only modern medicine knew
that you could heal yourself simply by
standing in front of a heater ah man the
wonders that this holds hmm so I guess
there's a mechanic probably I can't stay
out in the cold for too long or else I
will die I will die dead dead die I will
be very dead when I die understandably
ok so I'm going out there again let's
see all right let me venture out over
here this building seems now the hole
rip didn't do it which is probably a bad
sign but the door seems to be locked her
I'm gonna jump into the hole I need a
way to reach that opening so I need to
find a ladder of some sort can I go
under here yes I can but it doesn't go
anywhere
I probably shouldn't walk out into the
cold I don't think I've saved have I
thank you I have saved now prolonged
exposure can result in hypothermia good
thing I've got my magic healing heater
vent that's always handy I love being
out in the black snore
I'm here aha found you found you is
there a magic healing heater vent in
here hey what's behind the boxes what's
behind the boxes hello
Oh a dead body hello
are you okay he something is mitting a
strong sour smell could it be
smells like vinegar why is he covered in
it ill I don't want to know grappling
hook August oh yes mother certain
grappling hook I'm gonna go up I'm gonna
grapple something and I'm gonna be good
I know where I'm gonna use his grappling
hook by the way I'm gonna use it on that
jib big giant hole in the wall mmm
grapple grapple mine friend I use the
grappling hook I really need to throw it
how much can I grapple I grapple you I
grapple you there we go okay I'm in I
have made it into the building day 48
they still don't know that I'm a
snowflake
I have blended in is one of them loading
okay okay we're okay Oh oh hello uh
here's Johnny okay so we got the logo
new years Wow textures are pretty good
because there's a lot of detail on those
things
oh isn't that nice okay so now that I'm
in here
let's see NASA just temp Y range
misleading all sorts of stuff
is there anything important that I need
ah what is this rod justice the sweetest
justice of all the wrath of on guten
boom haha
what what what is that I have no idea
okay so anyway document this doesn't
look good
what was i running away from why are
there so many shotgun shells and what
the hell is going on in there oh is that
a dead kid ah crap wow what the hell
this happened
strange fungi seem to be growing on her
what the hell seems to avoid the light
very odd out oh okay so something on the
ground there is very toxic to me I'm
gonna stop being stupid
and going into that hello who you hello
weeba or the main file haha I like the
picture hey lash there shame to pay a
lot of better fairs going on in this
Electronics since last week any idea
where they come from
I thought all our stuff got EMT an
addict static shield so much for
state-of-the-art strolling down for a
match of Space Marines tomorrow you know
it Joe
signed Lizbeth okay so apparently
something happened with the station that
caused it to go all kerfuffled
and the door is padlocked hell hello
handsome ooh that's the guy from
prometheus 300 what's his name I don't
remember his name
I think that's a guy oh hello my dream
come true Thor you can is that is that
is that the guy from Thor I think that's
him I can't even recognize these guys
oh you can smash me with your hammer any
time if you know what I mean
okay so stay what get out here stay
illuminated why I don't even have a
flashlight what good is illumination
gonna do now the door is unlocked okay
all right so um looks like we're about
to get into the creepy part so this
would be a good as time as any duh
give a little pause here let's give
pause in this room so looking out of
this so uh things are about to start
getting a little freaky so stick around
for the next episode should be coming
very soon so thank you all so much for
watching hope you enjoy this and ignore
my stupidity in the first level I am
quite a large idiot when it comes to
these games so thank you all so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next episode bye bye
ah where did it come from nobody
don't betray me hey buddy buddy